nathalie normandeau est avec nous bon
soir madame normandeau
bonsoir mais savoir à j'imagine c'est
vraiment un mélange d'émotions vous avez
d'abord libérer tous les sens du mot de
ce fardeau l'homme en même temps vous
vous vouliez aller en procès pour
prouver votre innocence
absolument tout à fait ce matin lorsque
le juge a prononcé sa décision oui je
suis accueillie avec soulagement
évidemment vous en doutez bien après
quatre ans et demi de procédure qui
n'aboutissaient pas les larmes me sont
montées aux yeux lorsque j'ai entendu
juge pour annoncer sa décision parce que
c'était très rapide lent 2 minutes
c'était réglé le nôtre sort était réglé
le juge a prononcé l'arrêt des
procédures
ce n'est pas le dénouement que je
souhaitais je dirais même que je
méritais parce que moi j'ai demandé un
procès séparé des autres co accusés
j'ai posé avec mon avocat m e maxime à
roanne multitude de gestes pour
accélérer les procédures
pierre chaque fois que je posais je
m'adressais aux systèmes pour justement
être entendu la porte toujours se
refermer avec un moment donné je me suis
dit bon ben je peux pas vouloir plus que
le système est l'année passée en fait en
janvier dernier avec mon avocat j'ai
pris la décision de déposer une requête
en arrêt des procédures
parce que ils le jugent le souligner
sont effectivement ce n'est pas vous ou
votre avocat évidemment qui avait
retardé sciemment le procès pour que ça
tombe dans la catégorie de l'arrêt
georgian c'est à dire des délais
déraisonnables
vous vous avez voulu d'abord comme vous
avez dit avoir un procès seul pour ça et
plus vite
oui exactement parce que premièrement
c'est pas moi qu'a choisi de me
coaccusés la cette décision à la
partition dpcp et le fait d'être co
accusés on était sept au départ après
ceux dont on était on est deux on était
ses six coaccusés sa complexifier moi je
crois que ça contribue à complexifier
les procédures purement données voyant
tout ça je me suis dit ben là non j'ai
besoin d'être entendue parce que
j'aurais préféré aujourd'hui un verdict
d'acquittement
gg puisque le drame dans tout ça
monsieur roy puis je la vis comme une
injustice
moi j'ai demandé à rencontrer du pack
avant de m'arrêter là j'ai jamais pu
exposer ma version des faits aux
policiers
on est venu me
marc était à 6 heures le matin on est
convenus kanyama pas m'arrêter comme si
j'étais un ben dhia cas vers une bulle
guerre criminelle
après ça je me suis ok parfait là je
vais je vais faire en sorte que je
puisse être entendu dans le cadre d'un
procès je veux livrer ma version un juge
malheureusement je n'ai pas pu le faire
alors honnêtement la justice nous
offrent aux co accusés cette possibilité
de déposer une requête pour obtenir un
arrêt des procédures dans un contexte où
les délais sont jugées déraisonnables et
c'est la conclusion à laquelle est
arrivée aux gens qui vont dire ah oui
mais ce une technicalité elle n'a pas
justement elle n'a pas pu prouver son
innocence
là je vais essayer de vous poser la
question le plus simplement possible
avez vous madame normandeau a une façon
directe ou indirecte facilité
l'obtention de contrats publics à des
firmes de génie contre de l'argent au
plq
non non et je vous le dis là sans aucune
hésitation sans aucun faux-fuyant
et je peux le dire devant menée par
quelle caméra monsieur roy les
allégations de la poursuite de l'upac ne
sont pas fondées mon avocat a déclaré
quelques heures après mon arrestation
toute cette histoire n'aurait jamais dû
avoir de commencement malheureusement ça
a repris 4 ans et demi avant lui donner
raison
on m'a accusé à tort jamais jamais je
n'aurais dû être accusé puis ma
frustration là elle vient
essentiellement du fait que j'ai été
accusé à tort puis le fait que j'aie
jamais pu exposer ma version des faits
c'est quand même assez inusité écoutez
monsieur roy serrures kuhn accusé lève
la main à plusieurs reprises pour
écouter je veux mon procès moi ce que je
vois autour de moi c'est des accusés qui
tentent de fuir leur procès moi je lève
la main j'ai levé la main à plusieurs
reprises
on y voit la journée on m'a dit non on
fait comment donner demander monsieur on
vient on se dit mais à quel sens il faut
que je me à quel saint se doit et me
vouer le peut pour que je puisse être
entendu on voit la conférence de presse
17 mars 2007 je me suis en étant des
missions spéciales dont la présentation
d'un budget de carlos l'état où est le
pacte choisi cette journée là en pleine
journée de budget là on voit des images
une émission spéciale qu'on a défilé
avec marie maude denis en trop ma
question c'est est ce que dans votre
esprit
vous avez par procuration est arrêtée
parce que l'upac poids pour s'en prendre
aux grands patrons de votre parti
monsieur charest moche
j'irai parce que je peux pas je pas en
mesure de répondre clairement cette
question mais ce que je sais cependant
que je me suis toujours refusé à me
présenter comme une victime comme un
bouc émissaire c'est combien de fois
j'ai entendu
nathalie normandeau s'est jeté sous les
roues de l'autobus libéral c'est j'ai
entendu souvent mais depuis qu après une
nuit lorsque je regarde tout le fil des
événements monsieur roy
j'ai pas le choix d'arriver à cette
conclusion là qu'entre vous et moi tu es
le jour du budget que quoi qu'elle
conclusion que kaka qua non mais vous eu
confusion que je suis une boucs
émissaires dans toute cette histoire là
je suis une bouc émissaire je peux pas
il va d'autre conclusion que celle là
pourquoi parce que l'upr il faut se
rappeler le contexte là le contexte
robert lafrenière cherche être renouvelé
c'est important dans l'équation
le fait d'être arrêté le jour du budget
est ce que quelqu'un au québec qui croit
qu' il n'y avait pas de coïncidence
entre les deux événements c'est jeudi
roman donné leur faut se dire les vraies
affaires faisait les choses telles
qu'elles sont j'aurai l'occasion de
m'exprimer davantage sur le sujet parce
que je suis en train de coucher sur
papier toute cette histoire pourquoi
pour faire éclore la vérité parce que je
n'ai pas eu de forum pour m'exprimer sur
ce qui m'est arrivé il ya des choses le
jugement d'aujourd'hui avait des grands
passages caviardés parce que on attend
une enquête sur les fameuses fuites et
sans refaire toute l'histoire les fuites
ont causé des retards parce que les
autres co-accusés sont allés un an
procédures d'arrêt des procédures
justement contenu des fruits bref est ce
que cette enquête là va nous révéler
quelque chose vous pensez qui va aller
dans votre sens
écoutez le juge matin était très sévère
avec avec l'upac
bon on verra quelles seront les
conclusions du bo é d'idron les les
plaidoiries qui se sont tenues dans le
cadre de la requête en arrêt des
procédures là en juillet dernier il ya
des gens qui sont venus témoigner il ya
des choses qui ont été dites sous
scellées sous le sceau de la
confidentialité qui ne peuvent pas être
pour l'instant est révélée publiquement
mais ça on finira bien par le savoir
avec l'encadrent qui est un coup
monsieur roy si je peux pomme je peux
pour je peux pas répondre à la place du
pays vous comprendrez bien sûr mais
j'espère qu'on aura des réponses à nos
questions
bon allez vous poursuivre soit l'upac
soit le dpcp
ouais ça c'est la question à 100 dollars
aujourd'hui la jeunesse eut fait poser
plusieurs fois depuis ce matin je ne
peux pas exclure un scénario comme celui
là pour l'instant
mais en même temps je peux pas vous
répondre de façon affirmative 16e compte
tenu de ce qui m'est arrivé le petit
pigeon en même temps de gérer leur cette
décision qui est importante
en deux minutes le jugement redonné ma
liberté qui j'espère la est arrivé une
fois pour toutes on sait que le dpcp a
30 jours pour - pour poursuivre sa vie
pourrait en appeler du jugement
on verra ce qu'il décidera mais ce qui
est clair c'est que j'ai la
responsabilité pas vers moi même loti de
dire dans quelles sont mes options
maintenant il la grande question qu'il
faut que je me pose c'est est-ce que
j'ai le goût de me relancer de repartir
en croisade dans un système qui est
longue c'est ce que j'ai le goût de
repartir de d'initier une saga qui peut
encore durer quoi 2 3 en 4 ans il faut
et je faucheron je regarde tout ça mais
je prends le temps de le faire
retour en politique j'imagine qu'ils
excluent pour vous vous avez déjà goûté
à ça assez honnêtement cc66 la politique
j'ai payé très cher
le passage mon passage en politique il
ya des gens qui me demandait ce matin
qui me posaient des questions sur la
mairie de québec et tout ça mais il ya
des gens autour de moi mais sur wall et
qui ont énormément souffert de ce qui
m'est arrivé de mes proches mon conjoint
les gens de ma famille
il ya des gens qui ne comprendraient pas
le fait que je retourne ma politique moi
ce que j'ai ce à quoi j'aspire monsieur
roissy c'est aussi simple que de dire je
veux la paix et je veux retrouver de la
sérénité puis une vie normale c'est pas
compliqué le pioneer je vous montre à
trouver un logement pas d'emploi exhale
avait perdu notre boîtier la révolte
perdu votre emploi c'est à dire que tu
m'as donné les accusations au criminel
s'est dit si le t2 d'évoluer dans un
milieu des médias
puis je sentais aussi le besoin de
coucher sur papier ni mon histoire parce
que je me rends compte si les entrevues
que j'ai fait aujourd'hui là j'ai
beaucoup de colère et de révolte
politique
je suis révolté de ce qui m'est arrivé
parce que je me dis si c'est
profondément injuste
le sel de justice monsieur roy c'est pas
une affaire d'adultère ce n'est pas une
affaire d'approximatif tu n'as phone
c'est de droit et et je me dis
aujourd'hui bombay je comprends qu'il ya
des gens qui vont être en colère face à
cette décision du juge qui vont accepter
mais en même temps je me dis mais le
système nous offre cette possibilité
d'en appeler d'un arrêt des procédures
lorsque justement les délais sont jugées
raisonnables c'est les règles du jeu
vous avez raison d'ailleurs le juge en
terminant voilà je voulais c'est allez
bientôt mais le juge a dit il s'en
trouvera probablement certains dans la
population pour clamer la chance qu'ont
les requérants d'échapper ainsi à une
condamnation
il poursuit pire aucun juge voile sur ce
territoire là les requérants sont
dorénavant libre de toute accusation
relative à ce qui leur était reproché
ils sont donc tout aussi innocent que
quiconque vous pourriez croiser dans la
rue aujourd'hui
et c'est alors voilà c'est le message du
juge mais j'étais j'étais étonné j'ai
été étonné mais ce roi lorsqu'il a
prononcé ces mots parce que lorsqu'un
juge prononce un mot pendant une phrase
ans était on dit toujours les mots ont
leur importance surtout dans un tribunal
mais c'est fou mais ce roi de dire que
j'ai chappe à la justice parce que j'ai
été accusé au criminel c'est moi j'ai
fait les frais d'un procès sur la place
publique depuis quatre ans et demi
maintenant
puis j'ajoute à cela la commission
charbonneau je suis allé témoigner à la
commission charbonneau moment histoire
là avec la justice puis les aviez vous
envoler matière à douai ça dure depuis
2012 ouais là je vais défoncer un petit
peu mais ça sera pas long 1 mais soudain
est-ce que vous en voulez à ces gens qui
magouillent air au plq pical et puis on
le sait quand nul
on le sait le jeu pour revenir sur tout
seul vous n'êtes pas la porte parole du
plq
mais ce que vous vous en voulez à ces
gens là qui se promenaient que des
valises pleines d'argent comptant moi je
me serais aujourd'hui le j'en veux à
l'upac puis au dpcp qui me fait porter
l'odieux de tout ce système d'une autre
époque de financement politique illégal
c'est pas vrai nathalie normandeau ou là
à elle seule peut supporter sur ses
épaules tout ce système là c'est
extrêmement injuste de servir je le
répète de bouc émissaire gamme et un
juge
je vous le dis puis je résiste un peu
cette idée parce que je pense victime
dans la vie moi j'ai toujours assumé
j'ai toujours fait face au châtelet je
réponds aux questions des journalistes
n'en dirai pas ce que je vais je
continuer de répondre aux questions et
je juste préciser je vous dis merci
on va se reparler peut-être je veux
préciser que quand tout ça est arrivé
que vous étiez pas encore accusé mais
j'étais dans l'eau chaude j'étais venu
sur le plateau que vous aviez fait face
à la musique j'avais été une entrevue
petit peu différente de celle là disons
où je vous le thé sur rabbit hole et
fleurs l'ailé
les billets céline dion puis tous ceux
et votre chef de cabinet puis je vous
avais pas lâché là je vais pas lâcher
pied mais vous m'aviez dit je vois
revenir
peu importe le résultat quand tout ça
sera fini public est il alors je voulais
soumis aux gens voilà voilà voilà alors
à la prochaine merci merci au revoir